[موسيقى]
هنا في قلب بغداد مدينه الكاظميه ذات
الطابع الديني والتراثي في ان واحد بدا
جاسم الاسود ممارسه لعبه المحيبس التراثيه
كلاعب يافع في احيائها وازقتها العتيقه
يصبح فيما بعد ملك هذه اللعبه لثلاثه عقود
اللعبه تتلخص في اخفاء خاتم بيد شخص واحد
من الجالسين الذين يتراوح عددهم بنحو 100
شخص ومن ينجح في اظهار الخاتم يفوز بنقطه
على خصمه انا انبثاق بطولتي يعني
والفضل تقريبا العدد كان 500 ب 500 يعني
كان قبل عدد مفتوح ماكو بطولات رسميه هسه
صارت على النظام دوري وتصفيات كان قبل
يلبسون اي شيء سويناه زي موحد زي العربي
تراثنا الدشداشه وخليناه قانون ونظام
لا يوجد تاريخ دقيق للعبه ونشاتها لكن احد
ابطال المحيبس يقول انها تعود الى العصر
العباسي وان اللعبه جاءت عن طريق الصدفه
الوقت التاريخي اللي صار به صار
الخليفه العباسي الصبر الخليفه العباسي
ضاع منه خاتم بوقتها
فرادي يعرف المحبس وين جماع الحاشيه مالته
فراد يعرف المحبس وين شافه فراسته انه اكو
واحد وجهه اصفر فلذلك كشف المحبس وهي كانت
هاي الحادثه بشهر رمضان لذلك ارتبطت هاي
الحادثه بشهر رمضان
انتشار لعبه المحيبس وتزايد شعبيتها
وانتشارها في بغداد والمحافظات اخرجها من
المناطق الشعبيه الى القاعات الرياضيه
الكبرى لاستيعاب العدد الكبير من اللاعبين
والجمهور هي لعبها تراثنا يعني اجدادنا
واجداد اجدادنا يلعبون هاي اللعبه
يعتبرونها تعلوله بعد بعد الفطور يعني
ويتونسون ويلعبون
لعبه المحيبس تحولت من لعبه تراثيه الى
طقس من اهم الطقوس بعد الافطار والتي يحرص
البغداديون على ممارستها لوجود اطباق
الحلوايات وعلى انغام المربعات البغداديه
سامر الكبيسي العربيه بغداد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات